we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a caller saying
you know
you're still a shill
but you're the best chill
hi David this is Brad from Bloomington
Indiana right I just want to say I
always thought of you as a hill for the
past I don't know four years right I
gotta say
I Have Nothing changed but I think that
you're
the best show out there that's nice you
literally kill it every [ __ ] day
you're getting better at it
sorry I said the word stuff later
okay so
um you know the funny thing about this
is I think a lot of the people using the
word chill don't really know what it
means like for me the the idea of shill
is you are some kind of an accomplice of
someone who is doing something bad
um and maybe you're even a useful idiot
and that you don't realize that you're
doing it or maybe you do yeah I don't
know all the shill stuff it's either
people think I'm a shill for the
Democratic party despite not being a
Democrat and saying so many times I
don't care about the Democratic party
the Democratic party is almost just like
a corporation whose priority is to
perpetuate its own existence if the
Democrats are the better candidate I'll
vote for the Democrat I'll support the
Democrat but I don't really care about
the Democratic party some say that I am
a shill for a Socialism or communism and
of course of course I'm I'm neither a
socialist nor a communist so that one
doesn't really make a ton of sense it's
all very weird but I don't even know if
they know what it means to be a shill
but if you're gonna be a shill I'd
rather be the best and so I'll accept
the compliment I guess we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad yeah Alex Jones
is really wound up about today's bonus
show because Russia is no longer in full
control of any of the four so-called
annexed Ukrainian provinces I don't
think Alex Jones is happy about that
we're also going to talk about the
Supreme Court rejecting a gun rights
challenge to the Banning of bump stocks
this is triggering a lot of the more
guns and more places folks I guess I
would say and Kim is it pronounced
Kardashian this is not someone I'm
familiar with she has been charged by
the that's a joke by the way she has
been charged by the SEC for unlawfully
touting a cryptocurrency scam on her
Instagram account it is explosive and it
is wild wild stuff all of these stories
and more Hyperbole and conjecture on
today's bonus show when I'm joined by
producer Pat get instant access to the
the bonus show and I do mean Instant by
either signing up at joinpakman.com or
becoming a patron at patreon.com
davidpackman show both are options to
immediately get you access to the bonus
show I hope to see you then